good morning my name is Michael Hall I'm
a professor of biochemistry at the guild
centrum of the University of Basel and I
work on on cell growth and I biology is
asking me to tell you the story of the
discovery of Tor now tor is a is a
kinase it's a highly conserved kinase
and more importantly it's a central
controller of cell growth and this is
the story I'll tell you today so this is
the timeline of the Tor field the story
actually starts in 1965 and that's when
a group of scientists from Montreal set
out for Easter Island known as the Rapa
Nui to the locals and their prospecting
for for exotic microbes which produced
natural products of secondary
metabolites which they could then
develop into a an antifungal they did
isolate a bacterium from the soil
it was a streptomyces from which they
isolated a compound which they called
rapamycin after Rapa Nui however when
they started to develop this compound as
a antifungal they realized that had the
undesirable side effect suppressing the
immune system so it was then dropped and
was never further developed it's an
antifungal years later when
immunosuppressive therapy came into
existence this drug was then
rediscovered but now for use as an
immunosuppressive so it was now
developed for the very reason for which
had originally been rejected so we
started our studies on on RAF mice and
trying to lose state the molecular
mechanism of rapamycin action and this
story was started by by an outstanding
postdoc who joined the lab in 1989
Joao Heitmann he was a MD PhD who just
finished his PhD studies at in New York
at Rockefeller University and given his
medical background wasn't understanding
how how drugs functioned and we also
another fortuitous circumstance was a an
ongoing collaboration with Rao mova who
was a group leader at a local Basel
company by the name of Sandoz which is
now known as Novartis now Jo and Rao had
the brilliant idea to study the
mechanism of action of rapamycin by
taking an approach a genetic approach
with the simple eukaryotic yeast
Saccharomyces cerevisiae in particular
this is a brilliant idea because not
only could allow one to use genetics to
go after the target of rapamycin but it
was also an unusual idea because at that
time rapamycin was being developed
through it as the drug for use on humans
and everybody else is of course working
on the mailing cells understand how this
drug worked but the Jo and Rao
remembered that rapamycin had originally
been isolated as an antifungal and you
could therefore use use yeast and yeast
genetics in particular to to study
rapamycin action
so what Jo did was he grew up a culture
of our of our standard lab yeast strain
and then plated it on on solid media
containing rapamycin and the rapamycin
killed most of the cells which which
were plated on this on this petri dish
but a few spontaneous mutants arose he
then picked these mutants these and
several others he characterized by a
total of 20 different rapamycin
resistant mutants at least in the early
phase of the study and he had then
purified each one of these individual
mutants and then characterized them more
particularly he he determined the number
of complementation groups and what the
genes are mutated in these candies in
these strange two to confer rapamycin
resistance so Jo found that these uh
rapamycin resistant yeast mutants were
defective in any one of three different
genes the vast majority of mutations
were recessive and in the gene called
FPR one this is actually a gene which Jo
had already characterized the lab
the context of his earlier studies on
kind of rapamycin like drug called fk506
we also obtained mutes into novel genes
these mutations were extremely rare and
unlike the fpr one mutations were
dominant so this was the first the first
appearance the literature in 1991 of Tor
so this was the original identification
tore in this case as genetic loci in the
yeast genome we still didn't know what
the Tor genes encoded nor did we know
why these mutations were dominant and
and rare not answer these questions to
new students who joined the project one
was a genetic unter extremely bright and
hardworking Swiss student and then
Steven Halle well a British student who
was one of the more colorful members of
our of our lab as you can probably guess
from this photograph so what the
Jeanette and Steven did was they clone
the Tor genes from our rapamycin
resistant yeast mutants
and sequenced the these these genes both
the wild-type version and the rapamycin
resistance conferring version and this
allowed us to understand why the Tor
mutants were were dominant and rare and
the fpr one mutants were were recessive
and common and the reason relates to the
mechanism of action rap mice and that's
shown on this slide
this is Rasmussen drawn in red here this
is a very lipophilic molecule so it
simply diffused across the plasma
membrane it does not require any kind of
transporter in which when mutated could
confer rapamycin existence and once
inside the cell it then forms a complex
with other very small 12 kilo Dalton
protein called FK DP which is absolutely
essential for drug action the toxic
agent is the rapamycin FK BP complex'
drug alone does nothing and the fpr one
or the FK BP protein is not only
completely essential for drug action but
it's not required for cell viability so
any simple loss of function mutation in
the gene encoding this FK BP protein
confers complete rapamycin resistance
and such mutations would be recessive
that's why most mutations were in the FK
BP encoding gene and why these mutations
or recessive tore on the other hand and
this is just a very small portion of
tour tours about 300 kilo Dalton protein
as compared to this 12 kilo Dalton
protein here so you can see this is
indeed a very small part of the of the
tour protein this is the FK BP replies
and binding site in torque
and unlike FK BP or is completely
essential for cell viability and
therefore it can tolerate very little of
mutation in fact every mutation we
obtain which fell into the Tor gene
modified a1 residue they also in the
same codon which modified a residue in
this alpha helix which was a key contact
site between tour and rapamycin so the
effect of these mutations was to prevent
the binding of rapamycin 2 to tour
without otherwise affecting Tour
activity and given that these mutations
were confined to this single codon this
is why the these mutations were
extremely rare and of course it
conferred rapamycin resistance in the
presence of a of a wild type copy of the
Tor gene which is why they were dominant
so these mutations were extremely
informative they not only helped
elucidate the mechanism of action of
rapamycin inform the fact that forms a
complex of FK BP it also led to the
desiccation of the binding site in in
the Tor protein and most importantly led
to the identification of Tor itself so
once we clone the the Tor genes and
sequenced them we found first of all
that the the two tour genes encode very
similar proteins these proteins are 70%
identical and they also turned out be
the founding members of this class of
kinase a--'s protein kinase is called P
I kinase related protein kinases and the
reason for that is they they they all
the members of this class of a typical
protein kinases resemble lipid kinase ti
kinases in particular since its early
discovery of Tor yeast
tours been found now in all eukaryotes
from yeast all the way to human and the
named tour from uses be kept for all
these organisms in the case of human
tour on
valiant or we call it mTOR for mammalian
for so this is where we were in 1993
after the cloning sequencing or of our
tour mutants we knew the tour existed
and it was the copy of the target of a
FK DP rapamycin complex and in this
model you can actually see this at the
time where we still thought tour was a
lipid kinase epi kinase in particular as
indicated by the p i-- the fossa pod not
at all in this figure we had no idea the
timeout was upstream and what was
actually downstream of Tor we also
incorrectly thought the role of tour was
to control g1 progression in other words
to control cell division but this turned
out to be wrong and in fact the role of
torque is to control cell growth and
here I have to make an important
distinction between cell growth which is
an increase in cell size or cell mass
versus cell division which is a increase
in cell number we never expected that
the tour would be a controller of cell
growth because as hard as it might be to
believe from the perspective of today in
those days nobody thought cell growth
was actively controlled in other words
there would be no system to control cell
growth it was thought to be a
spontaneous process that just happens
when nutrients or building blocks are
available so we had to do additional
research to eventually arrive the
collusion the role of Tor to is to
control cell growth we came to this at
this conclusion based on a great deal of
work not only from our lab but a large
number of other largely each labs in
this in those times which show the Tor
control is a large number of cellular
processes now these
the process can be subdivided into two
groups the anabolic processes which tour
activates and the catabolic processes
which tour inhibits so tour balances
these opposing forces of synthesis and
degradation in response to and this is
important in response to nutrients this
is also something we discovered in the
mid-1990s tours activated by by
nutrients so and then this led to the
model it tours a central controller of
cell growth
this is most photogenic li Illustrated
experiments done in Drosophila by Tom
Noize felt and then Bruce Edgar on the
far side here we have an experiment done
by Tom Noize L this is the fat body of a
fruit fly and what Tom did was he
selectively inactivated tore in these
two GFP expressing cells and as you can
see these cells are smaller than their
neighboring wild-type cell booth Edgar
did the inverse experiment what he did
was he hyperactivated tor signaling in
these GFP expressing cells and the
observe the opposite effect the cells
became much larger so the obvious
conclusion from these experiments which
were largely confirmation of work done
earlier in yeast was that the role of
tor is to control cell growth and
thereby cell size
now Tom no I felt the
experiment one step further by now
isolating a mutant fly to a mutant fly
in which all cells of the entire animal
I defected for tor signalling it's
important to point out that this tor
mutant flies a so called hypo morph
it's a partial loss of function if it
been a complete loss of function this
fly never would have been born given the
tour is absolutely essential for
viability so when Tom knew I felt
isolated this flaw he then asked the
question why is this fly smaller is it
smaller because it has fewer cells or is
it smaller because as a normal number of
cells but now each individual cell is
slightly smaller and he can answer this
question by by looking in the wing where
he could at the wing at the plane of
cells Glee so he could relatively easily
measure the size of individual cells and
count the number of cells and from that
he could extrapolate to the whole animal
and what he found was this the tourm
you'd fly had more or less the normal
number of cells but each individual cell
was slightly smaller so the conclusion
from this is the role of tor is not only
control cell size but thereby also to
control size of individual tissues and
ultimately size of the whole animal so
tor controls growth very broadly broadly
in terms of organism and broadly in
terms of physiological context
essentially any any situation in
eukaryotic biology where you see a
change in cell size there's a high
likelihood the tour will be somehow
involved
so here we had another conundrum we had
known earlier from our from our genetic
studies yeast that there are two tor
genes to tor proteins yeast and whereas
these two proteins were similar seventy
percent identical they were not
functionally identical and this came
from the observation that if we knocked
out the Tor one gene nothing happened so
we proposed it that tor - then has some
redundant function with with tor one if
we knocked out toward two alone the
cells died but they didn't die in the g1
phase of the cell cycle
and finally if we knocked out both tor
genes simultaneously the cells of course
still died but now they dies in g1 phase
of the cell cycle this told us that tour
2 has two functions tor one has one
function and that one function of tor
one overlaps of one of the two functions
of tor - so we didn't know what these
two so-called
functions work and how they control cell
growth
well again a great deal of work from our
and a number of other labs doing yeast
genetics found that these two separate
functions of Tor are in fact two
separate signaling pathways one is the
what we called the tor - unique pathway
and this signals to the actin
cytoskeleton and and we therefore view
this is a pathway which mediates spatial
control of cell growth the other
function of torque the one that either
tour 1 or tour 2 can perform this
controls all these processes which lead
to mass accumulation in response to
nutrients and we view this this
signaling pathway that is signaling
branch of torque is mediating a temporal
control of cell growth so we think the
logic of these two different tours
signaling pathways that they integrate
spatial and temporal control of cell
growth of course these two aspects of
cell growth need to be integrated
so at this stage we had another problem
and that is what determines the
specificity of the tours like in tour to
signal through both pathways but 12:1
only through one and we also did know
why they tour shared branch was
rapamycin sensitive whereas the total
unique branch was rapamycin resistance
and to tackle these problems the another
postdoc joined the lab Canadian postdoc
Ravi Louis who teamed up with my long
term technician Wolfgang hopeful eager
and they decided unlike our previous
work decide to take a biochemical
approach to understanding tor signaling
so Ravi did this he purified the two
tour of proteins and what he found was
that the tours did in fact purify Co
purify with other protein and we had
these purified or we now call Tork
complexes tor complex 2012 complex -
when he had these two purified torques
and the test tube we sequenced the
proteins
this allowed us isolate the genes
encoding all these subunits of the two
tor complexes and once we had the the
genes isolate he was able to knock these
genes out and we did this he found that
these two tor complexes corresponding to
these two previously identified tor
signaling pathways so at this stage we
started wondering whether the pore
complexes like tor itself might be
conserved all the way to human but to
address this question another postdoc
joined the lab Estela jacinto she joined
the lab from Michael Karns lab and was
the first person in my lab to start
studying tore in mammalian cells to ask
the specific question is his tour or the
tour complex is conserved in mammals
so she and and notably other members of
the Torah field at this time most
importantly David Sabatini
Kazuya Nozawa and qu yang Guan showed
that the two complexes indeed are
conserved in humans they are made up of
the same proteins orthologs of the
proteins that originally discovered in
yeast they phosphorylate or act on many
of the same downstream proteins to
control the same cellular process of the
bulk in cell growth
so the picture that you merge is if the
tor signaling network and we call it a
network because it's more than a single
pathway the tor signaling network is a
primordial or ancestral signaling
network which has been conserved all the
way from yeast to human to control this
very fundamental process of cell growth
now the sole exception to that statement
I just made at this part of the network
up here which is the growth factor or
insulin signal pathway this evolved much
later this evolved with multicellularity
and was then grafted on to the more
primordial tor singling pathway which
already existed in unicellular yeast and
the reason for this is that cell growth
control in meta zones is more complex
than unicellular organisms because in
metazoans is critical to control the
growth of every cell in the body with
every other cell in the body so you need
an input which controls growth over a
whole body plan and this is then what
the growth factors signaling input
provides this control of cell growth
over a whole body plan now I'd like to
end with a note on the clinical
relevance of torque
now know based on work over the last 15
years that tor signaling is is
functioning linked to a large number of
diseases all of which are characterized
by inappropriate or ectopic cell growth
these can be malignant forms of cell
growth such as cancer or more benign
forms of cell growth like cardiac
hypertrophy but not in all cases cell
growth which also underscores the the
function of tor as a controller of cell
growth
more recently towards been implicated
another set of disorders the so called
metabolic disorders and we know that
high chronically high circulating level
nutrients can up regulate tor even in
the absence of growth factors this will
lead to DIPA Genesis and obesity we
should and of course can lead to type 2
diabetes but we have a more direct link
to type 2 diabetes in the tor signaling
Network and that is that tor complex one
can negatively feedback on the insulin
signaling pathway by phosphorylating IRS
as a result of this high levels of
torque can lead to insulin insensitivity
which is one of the hallmarks of type 2
diabetes in this context some have
actually proposed using rapamycin as a
anti-diabetic drug so this would be a
fourth major therapeutic area for this
remarkable drug however I don't think
anybody's actually seriously developing
rap Ison's anti-diabetic because their
number of other complications or at
least one finding one one thing that
gives credence to this notion that
rapamycin could be developed into
anti-diabetic is that the world's most
commonly prescribed anti diabetic
metformin works at least in part by
down-regulating the tork signaling
pathway
so I've come to the end of the story of
the discovery of four or these three sub
discoveries of tor signaling the story I
told you span the years of 1990 to 2004
a lot has happened since 2004 as I said
the field is going even further there's
still a great deal of exciting biology
but that will have to be a story for
another day
you